I know you were supposed to be in
Batgirl I guess that project went away
but I wasn't that girl I we shot that
entirely
um where is it it's in a vault somewhere
why why is it what do you know about
this you shot it yes you played the
villain uh Firefly yeah yeah
it seemed like a good movie to you I
mean what you saw it was great they saw
it uh a Dylan below did the bad boys
movies are really good at blowing [__]
up and they love doing it you know like
right practical fire effects making
stuff go bang they're all over it and so
Firefly was right in their wheelhouse so
in Gotham never looked better cast as
Glasgow Scotland you know it's decaying
and
just gorgeous and it looks like it's
Gotham City you know it's perfectly cast
as you believe it no matter where you
look in the town if you light it the
right way
um yeah we look it was a story about a
guy who uh had been in the service and
his benefits were cut and he was very
angry with system and what else is he
gonna do but Burn It To The Ground
that's all you need to know super
villain right there so you've got some
sympathy to them you've also got some
Humanity to him and on top of that screw
loose because you know he's a bad guy
but is he really like all the best bad
guys you kind of like him a little bit
yes that that was this role and great
role it was a yes on paper very very
good I relished this part it was great
fun I really and you shot the whole
movie and they never put out bad girl
correct do you think it'll ever be seen
have you seen the actual have you seen
it no no I'm not no no I have I have
friends and co-workers and Associates
who've seen it they all say really good
things about it the thing about it was
it was screened in a garden variety test
screen it was a director's cut first cut
it wasn't finished I mean right I don't
know about you but I don't eat half
baked cake I don't wanna see something
that's not ready yet and the sad thing
is is that I don't know if it was judged
on the Merit it wasn't shown in the best
light that it could have had been
um I mean yes once you give a film to
the people in the world yeah it's hope
it's open season to criticize it or
praise it or whatever you want but this
didn't even really get a fair shake and
and that's you know that's disappointing
for obvious reasons but moreover because
little girls are going to have to wait
longer now before they can see
a Batgirl who they can identify that
says hey she looks just like me too
right in Leslie Grace and and she was
wonderful oh gosh she was good really
terrific she's a firecracker like like
dynamite comes in small packages for a
reason like
she's a Dynamo